se protéger se dégager d'une attaque
voilà l'une des multiples techniques du
taitsou littéralement traduit par
technique du corps une discipline
sportive dérivée des arts martiaux basé
sur la selfdfense donc une intéressante
c'est comme la 1 on a 80 techniques
possible qui va de la simple saisie de
poignet en passant par les cheveux les
bras et tout bâton couteau
éventuellement chaise matraque enfin on
passe à peu près en vue sachant que le
but principal c'est un sport Daniel
Dubois fait partie des pionniers du
taijitsu une pratique développée en
France dans les années 70 après un
voyage au Japon aujourd'hui le
cofondateur participe à des stages comme
ici au club de Montini le Bretonneux
nous avons quasiment 40 % d'éléments
féminins justement et le but du jeu
malheureusement je dirais c'est d'éviter
savoir comment se défendre en cas
d'agression c'est vraiment un petit peu
ce qui ce qui prévaut au départ pour les
personnes débutantes
le taijitsu Montini le Bretonneux c'est
82 adhérents dont une section enfants
ouverte à partir de 6 ans une discipline
pratiqué par tous ce qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est tout ce travail d'énergie et
pour tout ce qui est aussi technique
comme là des mouvements de de torsion
des cercles qui nous permettent sans
force de pouvoir se dégager d'une prise
éventuellement en cas extrême on se
reçoit pas de vrais coup on essaie juste
de s'en sortir d'une situation pour
limiter du coup le danger en France plus
de 500 personnes pratiquent le taijitsu
ils sont 7000 dans toute
l'Europe